so I've seen some older videos where you
would talk with you know a couple of
gals in some case you know more than a
couple that you were seeing you were
dating you're having threesomes and
stuff like that
um do you still do that like you still
run a harem you mentioned you've got
some kids now
yep yep I've got yep I've got a couple
kids with different moms both Filipina
living in Thailand so I brought them to
Thailand well one's an American citizen
and
aside from that I have like a bunch of
Thai girlfriends and I'm just always
like swapping one out for another one
trying to just find who's
compatible with each other or who you
know is on board with my goals of my
life at the time
so yeah it's it's uh it's it deserves
its own reality show for sure because
I've never seen or heard of anything
like it before and I've never like on TV
I mean you have the Utah Mormon reality
show where the guys got the four wives
or something
though right like he doesn't look
anything like Tony huge yeah it doesn't
look cool like I don't wanna that
doesn't look appealing to me in fact I
think they're almost trying to make it
look unappealing like there's a yeah it
seems that way there's like an under
message of like actually you know this
lifestyle sucks but but mine is awesome
um because I do it to be awesome not
some religious or thing or anything I
just I just uh well I guess it started
when I was in America I had a different
girlfriend for every day of the week but
you know some are single moms which I
know is on your your stay away from list
or your red your red lights yeah
long-term basis is a thumbs down in
single months so you were you were
telling your audience to stay away from
the single moms and I was scooping them
up and putting them in my harem at least
they had at home yes it's easy you know
it's slow hanging fruit
um so talk about Harriman how you run it
because I mean you're clearly uh
non-monogamous you've got a couple of
Filipinos uh that are moms to your kids
you have two kids or
yeah two kids and I'll I'll have more
also in Thailand yeah is a strategy to
have as many kids as you can with as
many women or
well every kid is is also a huge cost
and and liability and something I have
to worry about I have to worry about the
mom because you know the mom's never
just gonna give me the child
um so I have to worry about like what's
the mom's future going to be like is she
going to be a good person in five or ten
years that I want to be the mom of my
child is she going to be a financial
burden uh so yeah there's still a lot of
consideration I'm definitely not just
trying to get just anybody pregnant and
and create a lot of liability for myself
emotionally and financially uh it's it's
more like I I would my perfect situation
would be to have all of my children live
in one house with like four children
four moms and they're all friends and
they all hang out together and they all
satisfy their own female emotional needs
and their their work on projects
together they take care of the children
together you know one woman can watch
the children while the other one goes on
a date night with me or you know like
this it's it's like it just seems almost
like I can't imagine a more efficient
way to run to satisfy everybody's needs
like the women need other women to talk
to they love women like to talk and and
men don't like to talk as much as women
so like they need to be able to talk to
each other a lot better to be talking to
each other in the you know the household
than going out and talking you know
going out to the random people that
aren't you know as trustworthy or
something and then build more long-term
female relationships with each other and
then also with the children uh you know
I I think in America it's really
unnatural to have like a you have a mom
and a dad and a kid and they're kind of
isolated and they watch TV and they're
isolated from the community and you know
you have to actually work hard in
America to be part of a community yeah
you don't have to go to church and you
need to like go out and do activities
with other children like it's a lot of
work whereas you could just have all of
this in one household and and everybody
needs satisfied and then my need of
having more than one woman is is
satisfied and it's also convenient
because when I had all these different
girlfriends it's a little bit like
before it's like running around to
different girls and it's time consuming
and energetic and I mean takes a lot of
energy
and it's uh when you when you have them
together and you just decide okay I want
to go with this one I want to go with
that one and also I I the other thing is
like I I women I will give you lots of
attention also and I want more of this
type of relationship but then when you
give me drama and stuff I'm literally
gonna walk to walk across the room to
the other girl and give her attention
and show you because of her good
behavior she's getting attention and
you're not getting attention and then
I'll explain it later and it's not a
punishment type of thing it's like a
training thing and then when I'm
training them I'm training them all
together instead of having to train one
girl and then like someday you lose her
and they're like oh my God all this
training I've trained this woman for
years now it was a huge waste of time
like I'm training them all together
and it's just more a lot more efficient
um what sort of challenges do you
experience dealing with like do the
multiple women live in the same house
with you like do they all live with you
yeah it's always it's always different
but usually usually they'll have their
own place
um just as like a backup if if uh
uh they so they don't feel trapped I
guess I guess the main really important
part of what I do is make sure the women
never feel trapped whatsoever because I
don't like in my mind if I feel like
they're trapped then I lose I I don't
know I lose attraction for them I mean I
guess a lot some men like to want to
control the woman and and trap her but
mine's the opposite I want to feel like
uh I'm I they're attracted to the honey
you know not afraid of the stick so I
want them I want to feel like they
really want to be here and that gives me
that gives me the power that I like also
which is that
um they come to me and if I'm doing and
and it it motivates me to be really good
too because then I want to treat them
good because I want them to stay I want
to build the resources up so they want
to stay I want to create a good
environment for them so they want to
stay but then I also want them to go
back to their condo and once in a while
and see what it's like to be without me
so they can appreciate me more I really
just want to be appreciated and
respected and I've just found this way
of doing it to the way that I get the
most amount of appreciation and respect
like would you rather be appreciated and
respected than loved
like what would be more important to you
I don't the the love definition is
really confusing to me and I and I and I
like talking about it and exploring it
but you know to women love is something
very different than it is to men and
then it's different between people
um I guess I guess one of the ways I
feel loved by like my main girl right
now is I feel like we could like deal
with anything with each other and she's
not gonna leave because she she's like
in her mind she sees herself with me
forever is there a hierarchy like like
there's your top girl and there's like
number two and three like how does it
work are they all treated the same yeah
there always has to be a hierarchy
that's one thing I learned about women
if there's if there's not a hierarchy
then they will end up in battle with
each other battling for the hierarchy
like they will create a war to determine
the hierarchy if you don't lay down the
hierarchy
um
yeah I've I've had conversations and I
have um you know I do some private
consults and stuff like that and I've
doubled some pretty interesting people
like athletes and actors and uh you know
BC guys that you would know if I mention
the names and I was talking this one guy
once and he had uh I think three or four
kids with uh two or three different
women and
you know I was asking myself so how do
they all get along like do the women
actually like each other and he said no
they hate each other
um
I'm assuming you probably deal with the
or or have dealt with something similar
as well how do you deal with the you
know the female drama you know between
women because you know I've often said
you know having having multiple women
and multiple girlfriends can be a bit of
a pain in the ass if if they you know
become that that dramatic like women are
women at the end of the day like
intimacy with a woman is pretty much the
same like you know with small variations
but then it's like what are you dealing
with when you're not being intimate you
don't have the variety and it sounds
there's a variety of conflict and fights
between them and all that sort of stuff
like how do you like what's your
thoughts on that sort of stuff now
there's a great example of of this when
I was uh in Thailand and I had two
girlfriends living with me full-time and
it was like the best relationship
situation of my life it was threesomes
twice a day always together
I could go with one or the other at any
time I didn't have to have them both
together but I just really liked having
them together every time
and then their work together and then
wow there's some times where one would
be massaging me and one would be cooking
for me and I'd just be like oh my God
this is this is just my Paradise this is
so perfect and they were such they were
they worked together so well I'm waiting
for the butt but but okay I had cameras
installed in my in my condo too so I
actually watched this whole thing happen
I'm I left to America for I well I
traveled around the world but I I went
to America and then I traveled around
the world and then I came back and uh
they're fighting
and they're fighting because
well
in the end it's because they both are
different style people and they weren't
really compatible but because I was
there and I'm the leader it's kind of
like going to a job and you know when
you have the boss there you're working
for the boss and you're working towards
a common goal and you you kind of you
forget your differences you're you you
have to to do you know act appropriately
but then when I'm gone and I watch on
camera man one girl's one girl's messy
she's not cleaning up after herself and
the other girls yelling at her like yeah
instead of like Tana King with her hey
could you be a little bit more clean
could you clean up after yourself no
she's like yelling at her
and so they've had a fight and then that
was it that I could never get them
together again it was ruined if I was
managing them at all times then but but
the thing is I don't also want to manage
them all times I do want to be able to
leave I do want to be able to go on
vacation and come home and then be
together so then I realized okay the
girls have to be compatible within
themselves if they're going to live
together I can't be babysitting them all
the time so that was one of the lessons
there's been so many lessons learned a
lot of them the hard way like this some
of them through like David Bond for
example I did David bonds um millionaire
Social Circle and I went to Philippines
and learned all all the Harem Quest
that's what he calls it for him the
Heron Quest so I called mine like the
Tony huge Harem Quest is the David Bond
Harem Quest and I learned a lot of uh
you know things that I was missing from
him about how to manage a harem properly
because you know this is this is not
something you ever like TV doesn't media
doesn't teach teach you this I think a
lot of what people learn about
relationships is from media and TV like
what they're supposed to do Hollywood
yeah sitcoms yeah there's not there's
nothing really to watch that's realistic
about running a harem you have to learn
it all through trial and error it's
really it's really a long process so it
was nice to to learn from someone in
person
who'd been through and fixed some of the
problems that I hadn't figured out how
to fix yeah
is there um
I mean like overall I'm guessing because
you continue to pursue the lifestyle you
find that the benefits outweigh like any
cons like the benefit of the variety and
the fun and all that sort of stuff it
outweighs the cons of the drama between
well I do think about giving up on it
constantly but then I remember that if
you give up on this it's very hard to
get it back like the girls that I have
right now they they expect this Harem
lifestyle now if I give them
um a more monogamous lifestyle then it's
going to be hard to go back to being
polygamous so like I need to keep
reinforcing that I am polygamy if you're
with me you're part of this and
uh yeah so I I do think about giving up
on it though because at certain times
you know when you're when you have one
girlfriend or wife and she gives you
drama it causes you a certain amount of
stress now can you imagine like three
girls all on their period at the same
time yeah all giving you drama at the
same time it's so overwhelming you just
wanna you you just you just shut down I
mean it's it's yeah you have to
well to some extent you have to rise up
and be a Superman you have to be like a
king and you have to lay down the law
and you've got to be like a father with
10 children right and and you're you're
the one setting the rules and the
standards and enforcing
and on the other hand it's like it it it
sometimes reaches a breaking point where
it breaks you as a man and you just
crumble into depression and then you've
got instead of one woman like uh
emotionally attacking you you've got
three or or more and yeah can be over
well and then you think like okay I I
can't handle this I'm gonna I should
just give up on this I think it's
impossible this is maybe maybe monogamy
is you know the way to go
but in the end I always think like man I
just really I have two choices like any
of us do in life we can either just
completely settle where we're at which
is totally fine like you can settle and
be happy like once you've got the life
you want you could settle and you could
keep that forever or like you could see
what the next chapter has in store for
you
and for me like it's like I want to see
the next chapter I want to get through
the hard time with the Harem and I want
to see what it's like when I make it to
the next level
that's interesting man you've said
you've shared some really uh great
insights on how you live your own
personal life with you know the women
and like did you marry them or is it all
just like they're the mother of your
kids you know you take care of them it's
just understanding right but in law
school I decided I would never get
married when I had family law in law
school I said
I am why would anybody ever get married
and this education about how the family
law system works that we learn in law
school should be taught in high school
yeah I mean ditch the you know gender
gender awareness class or whatever and
add in like family law yeah I've always
said like uh you know like 18 year old
boys should be taken down to a family
court for an afternoon just to watch
what happens to men when they go through
divorce render so they have at least
some understanding of what the world is
really like because even I didn't
understand like I just signed up for
marriage I'm like sure take the vows if
it doesn't work out you can untie the
knot and then after a 20-minute
conversation with my lawyer when I was
like okay I need to get out of this
um I was like are you like
serious like this is the way that it
goes for most guys I have to play these
games this is this is how it can go sort
of thing so well you know in in high
school maybe you have like a drug a
recovered drug addict come to school and
tell you like oh don't do drugs everyone
in my life now I'm clean and I teach
people how not to do drugs
married guy come in and go don't get
married it's going to ruin your life I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out